hello folks happy Thursday I'm joined by
the young one the young boy himself
Michael hi I'm I think your first like
actual like playing like live outside of
extra life yeah but I brought you on
because you are one of our one of two
tech gurus here at game swapper as you
and Jimmy of course and recently you did
an article kind of just comparing and
talking about pub G versus fortnight and
there's kind of in this huge popularity
shift kind of with fortnight to so
especially with Battle Royale I think
mainly probably because it's free but
we'll talk more about that I actually
didn't ask you where the best place to
put the picture-in-picture was but we'll
assume it's the top right for now snap
yeah I think they'll be all right
all right once you get in the game
you've played how many hours have you
played a fortnight now I played about
10-12 hours of straight up yeah battle
royale in fortnight so I'm familiar with
the mechanics how things work but I'm
not a pro by any means yeah more more
seasoned with pub geodesy yeah
well I've also reviewed pub key for a
GameSpot I ran I put in like over 100
hours in that game so obviously I'm more
familiar with that but at the same time
I think that you know digging it's a
fortnight I definitely see which is what
my feature article is about is uh you
know looking at the differences between
the two games because they play out very
differently yeah as we'll see here yeah
I'm gonna ask you about that some of
those things some of those differences
some of the things that you like or
dislike compared to you know when you
play pochi this is part of it like
you're gonna see more of it in the
actual game but you know you break down
walls and things like that for materials
because there's actually building in
this game which is kind of a big deal
because it lets you get to higher places
it also helps kind of like fortify you a
fortnight against other players yeah and
once you get really good with building
like some of those pro streamers and
whatnot you can build like crazy stuff
protect yourself but appreciate all you
guys tuning in today I'll be moderating
the chat so if you guys have questions
or comments or tips for us please send
them on over I'm gonna move this picture
picture and hope that it doesn't break
I'm pretty sure let's see where should I
go imma try and go to retail role
alright are you starting off more
conservative run here or are you gonna
try to go like like litem lies yeah I
don't know see I'll try and play a
little little carefully here okay start
out alright but no promises cuz you
never know what might be around the
corner yeah I mean we're just playing a
little warm-up match like right before
this and you're and we ran into somebody
yeah it was a close call for you but you
ended up having the shotgun which proves
very good in close quarters in this game
for sure yeah
so hopefully I have the same luck I had
before here when I was warming up well
there's a lot of people here man it's
gonna get spicy that yeah well I guess
well let's do spicy right now oh you're
gonna get spicy yeah man I didn't drop
fast get that adrenaline flowing our
pressure is on y'all don't know this but
I'm sweating that's fine they can't see
the sweat not yet all this doors open
I'm alright so here we go this is the
first phase got a little shield potion
that's a kind of different to I guess
it's kind of like would you say it's
kind of like a painkiller or not really
the shield potion is the armor in this
game I guess yeah okay oh you're gonna
shower oh wow what a way to start yeah
alright damn I could have sworn that one
I was like dude do you not hear this I
hear gunfire in my left ear and like I
see your life just like oh so here's the
first part you can get easily distracted
just trying to farm up some meds you
know getting those jitters out early
that's the let's part okay I was Wolf's
taking down the wall to your fare I
thought those sounds were the wall
breaking down but that was actually me
getting shot up as y'all saw all right P
man yeah Doughboy yes I am reading the
comments don't worry I already told
Michael you can't there's no way well I
shouldn't say there's no way but it's
highly unlikely that you'll top our pub
G stream where me and Nick literally got
zero kills in like two hours
so if you get one kill I think
I think yeah you're better than Nick
however I guess for funsies I've never
played for at night someone just asked
me if I played it dragged a curtain hey
Calvin I know who you are okay I could
butcher your name whatever
I've never played but maybe to spice
things up maybe I'll play around later
and see how poorly I do Oh
once I started playing pop G with Nick
those couple matches I was like okay I
see the appeal here and why it could be
fun and also just like the tension there
there's that it's that tension that
really kind of elevates the game I feel
like yeah definitely I think more so
with I talk about this a little bit too
in my article is that I really feel a
lot more more attention and intensity
with pub G just because of the nature of
how you play that game it's more of a
tactical shooter than this is and also I
think the art style really drives like
it takes a lot of stress off of me
yeah it's like aesthetically it's not
the same you don't feel the like weight
and the stress that you're talking about
yeah
like as like a purse like I don't know
it's it's still videogame but you know
obviously they they look very different
yeah that one's a little bit more
realistic I guess yeah there's a very
cold vibe to pub G whereas here it's
like you know it's all writing you get
whoop like I just didn't like that's a
good thing is like you just get back in
a match
Cameron Walker the minigun update
actually got delayed I was checking to
see if we we had it but uh it's not out
yet and that's just according to for
tonight's Twitter there's no ETA
apparently on when they're gonna release
so we just have to kind of stay tuned
what's up game King welcome to the chat
thank you for tuning in appreciate it
Jermaine asking who's on ps4 a couple of
my destiny friends will help us war I
haven't I haven't played it but they
seem to all be having a pretty good time
with it the ones that are playing it I
will say though I bet you it at least
for me it would be easier to play for
tonight on ps4 because there's probably
a lot more mmm like noobs or like you
know it's it's a harder to aim with a
with the thumb stick instead of a mouse
keyboard you know I mean this game is a
little more forgiving a lot more
forgiving actually than
do you want to close that aiming oh snap
I just busted the floor oh you got some
ammo there if you need it
animal box what's in here the other
thing too is like at part of the looting
in this game as you can see Michael he's
he's kind of breaking down the walls
also you're breaking down the walls
because there's loot or treasure chests
that have better guns and there is like
rarity of guns which how much like how
different is like your common AR that
you have right now versus like a
legendary like it do you feel like it's
like substantially better or it's kind
of just like okay well I at least in my
experience it kind of shoots well shoots
the same but you the you do a lot more
damage with the higher tiers of the same
gun okay so you definitely are trying to
get some of these you know rare that
maybe epic or legendary type weapons and
there definitely are spots that I feel
like we'll have a better chance of like
a chest like I know like roofs that you
then like break sometimes well like
underneath that roof will be like a
little you know it face attics are in
that basement attic that'll have stuff
and then the other thing if that I
figured out that I that Michael hadn't
known till today it was that if you aim
for that actual reticle like here you go
that no chest
wait it might be beneath okay so like if
you aim for the reticle actually breaks
it faster no which is kind of what you
want to do I'm not sure the math on how
much faster I just know it's like you
should aim for that yeah takes
considerably less hits if you're able to
focus on that reticle that garage oh man
I got a long way to go though and
there's no is it there's no vehicles
right no okay hope you watch others
doing in there
frigate you legit there's a dude I just
saw him in the window at the school you
guys shot II oh oh he's got hella stuff
dude get man dude take the news and go
like heal yourself see that's my problem
I think I would I would be screwed
because I would just be having too much
fun looting dude you need it you need to
go bandage bro
you're making me real anxious I'm back
to get you just
do it's already down in the open oh no
no no open I'm in the garage we're all
but like I know I know I don't even like
tactically there you go thank you see
this is how a pro works dog dude so you
killed that guy out of the common he had
a blue it must have been that headshot
bro
oh-ho I'm doing this I'm warming up I
did get the jitters out don't don't put
too much pressure on all right well dude
I we already I like I said we're racer
past the last name so we going up we're
like we're like we're like 10 minutes I
already talked yeah I don't know if
Nick's watching he's trying the real
salty about that but okay I love you
[ __ ] the way life yeah it's all good
oh I got a sniper though so how y'all
feeling about how you feeling about the
sniper good where there's always a chest
in the middle that's Oh deal oh let's go
cheap all right don't you crazy bro why
didn't you just use your AR I crumbled
under pressure man ah I got it I got too
cocky now he's like cool thanks for all
the gear a lot so the bear man I hope
you enjoy my stuff oh well okay so the
first match I got zero kills I think
even good in there oh dang well I risked
my life for nothing
yeah yeah that's what happens in these
games just take over I dude I don't even
play bro
I probably die right away I don't know
what I'm doing man well at least y'all
got to see one kill yeah it's got two
kills now yeah exactly
just like slowly ramp up expectation
yeah I think I think I'll be fine
I haven't really built anything yet
though I haven't gotten to that point
where I needed to build anything but
hopefully I'll last long enough
let jelly Skelly says clean-ass june
sweater jeunesse every day is great yes
yeah oh it's not a sweater though so I
know it's a shirt close enough that
swole noose right the site all right
let's get it that's pretty good though
all right I feel like is that how you
play it poke gee you just run around and
open mmm
well I'm not really old I think I think
well the way I play pop G is very I
usually play in squads - yeah so I
constantly have it's like a game of
leapfrog almost when you play in the
squad because oh yeah I don't I think
well because every time I want to play
pop G there's either like y'all and the
office is down to play or my homies back
home want to play - so I don't really
have
I don't really had much time to play
solo in pub G that's probably the least
the mode that I played the least but in
for tonight I've played almost
exclusively as solo but I think that the
building mechanics really shine
especially when you're playing in squads
in fortnight because y'all can stack
stuff on each other build huge buildings
like real quick it's it's insane how
like high-level players can do that so
maybe you'll see it here I got a couple
got a couple people dropping this zone
or I'll that's a lot about to get spicy
I need to get down there real quick come
on can't you just let go the glider oh
yeah once you get to a certain point you
have to parachute oh sorry you got any
are all right I think you'd rather have
a shotgun though real talk I don't know
dude yeah shotgun is so I feel like
shotgun so Opie let's go all right I'm
gonna pull up on them you crazy
it's alright Eric can you cover no I'm
about to go wait I'm not even breaking
anything - oh I am I'm about to go run
up on this floor right now by breaking
the wall let's go let's go oh they got a
shield though just watch this again
watching um this is this is bad tactics
by the way I know I wouldn't do this if
it wasn't on the stream yeah if I was
trying to actually what do you mean I
want you to Oh green AR green ow
what what you know sure no you trying to
scare them yeah come in they probably
already busted like out of here I'm
probably getting flanked right now you
know it the second yeah all right we're
already back at the and how we did last
time which is already an improvement
yeah this is pretty good I feel alright
and we're in this there's a lot of good
there's a lot of peeps here though you
bet you bet yeah there was at least like
five others wait hold up I should
probably gathering resources right now
but I want to drop that get that out of
my inventory because I don't need that I
hear some resources I'm totally like
make myself vulnerable making yourself
vulnerable like taking away your cover
fire oh there's a sometimes in life you
got to admit when you mistakes were made
ooh no mistakes over here boy all that
automatic shotgun yeah let me get that
alright I'm just some chill right here
okay how are you all doing today uh yeah
we doing good
well the minigun slow you're moving you
think I would have to think so I have no
idea how that I don't know it's not
since we can't play with it I can't tell
you for sure let me get some gather some
wood real quick get that wood I think
there's a basement
oh oh oh damn I thought that someone
yeah I don't know that is kind of
distracting though I guess I suppose
that's part of the part of the challenge
ain't nobody grilling that steel mmm
that steel reserve that's what I'd be
sipping on dawg site all right I feel
pretty good about this one but I said
that last time then I got rolled up on
so their difference there was you was
trying to do some sniping and I was like
I should please until later until you
start you know building up that
confidence
ya know I guess I got a little game we
evolved we get stronger we get better
you a motivational speaker son yeah you
know you get two kills and hopefully
three kills Hey for the folks in chat
what's the equivalent of the chicken
dinner in fortnight like what are we
looking at what is that call man
unfortunately I don't know never a
garden one right you said you got a last
second places yeah I got a lot second
places but I just I can't get on that
same level of like look at this someone
already built I want you to drink your
other shield but hold on here don't do
that out here yeah that's probably a
good idea man got your back yeah chats
coming in clutch man yeah I need y'all
help sometimes you gotta be careful
though sometimes check chappie Chad's
gotten me a couple times he must've got
like a purple or something for him to
not to drop blue yeah I think it goes
purple than yellow or yellow than purple
legendary and epic oh yeah someone
looted yeah isn't yellow is the highest
rate and then it's blue purple yellow
green blue purple yellow I would assume
that's like almost like every game yeah
they still want you to drink your shield
okay thank you for reminding me
it's called victory royale if that's
true that makes a lot of sense
thanks me Lowe's Babic 85 thank you jazz
Karan Singh oh oh I hear someone that
was right in stuff hmm I don't have good
positional audio or I may be on my ears
it's just clogged
that's probably my ears is clogged
probably for you I was just a legend
Ares oh he's got that tree suit you've
never seen the tree suit oh that guy was
trying to be sneaky and then he just got
got he got god oh my god oh yeah I'm
over whelmed pistol
take the shield though is that grenade
NASA nade I don't really boogy bombs I
guess I'll take it get bopped that's
right
wait I we doing good bro
I never strapped up a bush before oh
look a better for outside Naz is good
inside I'm a houseplant yeah you a
houseplant okay mm thanks creeper stash
101
oh no that wasn't very noob like their
Chris Bolek I think the guy in the
hiding in the bush in the the house was
doing some noob stuff yeah was he a
houseplant but he was like walking
trying to make a youtube video my bad
for ruin it for him nah dude you did the
right thing yeah I proved oh man check
the circle then you circle or we could
we're still going are we still good oh
we we stand pretty God blue AR Green
auto shotgun you got a bush dude you're
gonna die like that room no Kim Drago
says Gold pistol does 70 damage to the
head and that's if we can hit him in the
head hey man you saw my aim earlier it's
all Fleet Skol
oh alright this is this is in this point
of the game especially when I'm playing
pub G as well as I like the chill when
I'm in the circle and I'm like 37 36 35
now oh geez this is good we're right
we're good how do you get a job at
GameSpot says creeper stash 101 it's
part of its luck but obviously a CBS
Interactive has job postings so you know
when you see those job postings you
apply for it it definitely helps to have
somebody refer you if that's possible
and then just interview well or have a
good demo or a good real sorry or a good
resume those are obviously important
things Chris Bowen says it's better for
outside yeah yeah see we're part of a
very tall tree here okay maybe not
all right now that was a bad idea I was
just right here is the question do you
know what it's like to try to shoot with
that thing on
let me see I don't know if I want you to
give your position away though use the
suppressor let's see oh you can still oh
that's fine
yeah see like it clears up for your for
your 80s right there
oh my god I am I am right I'm ready to
go I feel good about this one what can
you use a silencer I'm gonna stop
backseat game oh no no that's all good
got that golden bullish that's right
Keith Richards liver 420 look at us do
we a pretty different though it's very
different I guess I guess if you're not
looking though around you could easily
get crept oh yeah especially if your is
not as good as or if you're as bad as me
in recognizing like the environment you
could easily walk by this if you like
never seen it before - cuz deathful in
the house I was like what is that is
that a glitch or something cuz I haven't
played about like 1012 hours of this I
and see nobody do that
kiyo Freitas asking why do we keep
running around with the pickaxe being
reckless on purpose he's just you know
he's not afraid he don't hate dog he
wants to show you how quick he can
switch to his next weapon it's it's uh I
have to I want to take this off how do I
take any know how to I can take this off
I don't want to wear this anymore
there's actually drawn attention to me
as I'm running across the field so yeah
they'll never know it's like it's like a
metal gear right now oh man you're not
even in the circle he knows that now we
on our way we not that far though we're
good
I got full health full armor and let's
go I'll switch my AR real quick we will
become the bush in 76
that will happen wash yeah no beating
around the bush here this has been
broken down all right dude we say we're
trying to we're trying to get a victory
royale here it's not what they call it
yeah it's a victory royale that's either
way this one's going a lot better where
we got we doubled our amount of kills we
got the golden bush we had golden
silencer oh you see someone don't right
dude you got faith huh hmm there was a
time before we started screaming that I
was like there's dude don't do that
there's no way you're gonna kill him and
you killed him so I I can't say nothing
except now after watching you snipe I
might be hesitant to be like yeah my
sniping is let's let's reel that back a
little bit that's all right oh man one
shot takes the bush away says Samuel
Bono's oh that's good to know
Oh purple oh snap
someone's up in here the whole yeah you
sure oh he's right there what's coochie
butch life oh my oh god oh god oh god oh
god good thing we had that shield oh
that did he have a scar he's got a lot
of Purple's like that well trap will
shield get a shield thing grab the
shield later oh snap I didn't see that
yeah I'll bet I'm strapped that up right
now so I can pick up my assault rifle
back you right out in though you making
a bold plays oh I know I miss their bold
I'm getting lucky Oh
bold move cotton oh man all right I'm in
the circle I'm my heart's beatin my
hands it's like okay so like you see all
the guns on the floor it makes it
doesn't that just like oh there's a drop
too
doesn't that just raise your awareness
of like where creeper stash
yeah because like you're like running
you know let's say towards this circle
and you notice like oh [ __ ] there's like
all this crap on the ground there's
probably in pub G because then like when
people die there's like a like a big ice
box that's on the floor so I kind of see
but like it's one box Oh watching cool
blood oh this guy this guy's getting
what do something do something oh yeah
Guerra let's go let's go oh oh you're
trying to go oh you got the higher to
see that's that's the magic of building
in fortnight but this is the magic of
level skills right here boy oh I'll
bought to get rolled up on watch oh he's
on the other side now we play ring
around the Rosie
Oh what's up mmm I even sweatin it Lord
Yu's oh let's get some slurp juice the
hell is a slurp juice I bet that tastes
good is that like full shield no it's
like a gradual thing all right I never
had no slurp juice before what the hell
a whatever it don't matter
tactical shotgun take bolt instead of
semi yeah you're right
wait what does yourself right it's fine
he ain't he ain't gonna be using the
sniper I think maybe that blue sniper
out there is probably like a bolt
whereas you have a semi on this is my
single shot sir he's building I don't
care I got skills homie
oh my god please no not like this
Michael just use the skills that you got
I got plenty of that okay this is good
this is good you're buying times fool
thinks he's oh he's coming now
oh you good now oh yeah give me the AR
oh all day all day all day let's go
let's get it oh my goodness let's go
homie talk to ow
I shut up dude I I know nothing I'm just
gonna look at chat I need a I need a dip
to the circle though oh my god I got a
long way to go this is not looking good
though and you got no shield too
annoying we only got six seconds to mmm
oh I think I think up anyway we find
scoot circle is amove that fast
we'll see whoa build whenever you get a
so they're telling you to build when you
get shot at but like I feel like um
since you're not like used to it yet
like to do it really fast like that like
the pros do it I almost want to say what
you did was better which is the PUF G
strat oh snap someone's sniping you a we
could we got a house we got a house I
just build out so I can look tight
you silly that's fine though yeah y'all
can hate on my building skills design
right outside the circle just FYI so I'm
playing this like pub G where I usually
like sit around the edge of the circle
and like just try and peek to get a lay
of the land look at this oh oh I'm like
giving my position away - oh man it's
all good he gave me his position oh he
build the tallest tower yeah you like
RAM this is a good example of like what
he's still creeping up top he'd be head
glitching what's good you're right I
used to be a pro Oberon see us boy let's
go I don't think what you have is an OP
right now but I definitely don't have an
off Terry Shipman size building skills
take time don't sweat it yeah thanks
yeah I think the building part is worth
like the next level meta is it's like oh
oh you getting cross-wired I'm getting
crossed though I think good he would
have to come down the hill to challenge
you and I don't think I'm still in the
circle stuff so then you should find a
way to bandage at some point probably Oh
circles small I'm gonna try and show oh
hell no I got a what's good oh no
problem not scared you're like you want
shoe rocket I'm a dance on you little
toes right here what's good just a new
meadow you won't know right you can't
you can't possibly know that you're
gonna heal down there right oh is that
what I should do
I know um ah my heart's beating Oh
what's up oh my god I got team fortress
I got blown to smithereens homie oh man
oh that's a good round and that's good
no I mean five kills a five kills you
know we're not up well now the ceilings
too hot so yeah like that was tough
because you know the other player
obviously had high ground right and you
had to deal with the other guy that was
trying to deal with him too and he was
already starting to build you know no
someone was saying use a jump at I don't
even know what that is yeah
that's another thing I could use to get
up higher so yeah that what you dropped
what y'all just saw there was an example
of how foreign aid is very different in
the late game which I obviously all saw
that I'm not terribly good at but you
know you always want to get higher
ground and the way you get there is by
building staircases and you saw like two
different players were doing that yeah
like that's how you get to the positions
the advantageous positions yeah
in fortnight and I feel like what he did
in a way too was like I mean granted
maybe he was he didn't necessarily mean
to do this but like by you kind of
approaching him he was like cool I boxed
you in and I can rock you like I put you
in a box but yeah I think the only thing
I would have even considered doing is
like I would have maybe bandaged like
when you got to the to the hill on the
guy that was up top he probably did have
an angle on you so maybe you could
manage with the circle also was about to
move so that would have been tough and
yeah I felt good about that one I mean
it's better than we got the golden bush
like yeah I saw some do you think a
couple new things you think I don't want
to say that but I'm afraid we may have
my we'll see so what's up Abdul Rahman
Kazu I'm gonna call you a duel Cossack
about that what's that man that's a good
round to be honest as wrath upon thank
you I mean like thank him Michael good
job is taking a play probably not McFly
I've never played but maybe once just to
see how awful can be if I get one kill I
think if I get one kill that success
that's a success in my book like that's
how I felt about the first time I played
pub G on xbox that's telling it goes
like man if I can get it one kill that's
already a win and I got five kills I got
seven that game now that was complete
another luck and I don't think that
would ever happen for now is because
there's more systems in play I feel like
poke Gees a little well I probably
watched more pub G than I have fortnight
so I have a better understanding of that
game but I just feel like there's a few
more mechanics and layers to this game
oh [ __ ] did you have a gun already they
probably got they probably hellish
strapped up already man I don't know I'm
so is there a trick to falling faster or
no if there is I don't know of it
then who's gonna dance I can dance all
day yeah you did dance on the guy that
shooting I know I actually hit like I
don't even I forgot what the emo key was
oh my god I got shotgun I'm not gonna
mmm
he killed someone huh yeah did I that's
fine one of the that quite yet now yeah
yeah we need we need to be able to fight
on an even playing field no oh man he's
got a green something I don't know it is
I need a name all right let's go
oh there's a white AR yeah this is
probably hiding around some corner it's
a burst rifle I don't really like the
burst rifle but can be true a shotgun I
mean here yeah this is probably a good
area like a pulse rifle right now in a
close quarter you better be accurate AF
boo there's there's something green in
there yeah probably get that and
probably dip out to your right
oh that was embarrassing
[Laughter]
why I have more fun watching battle
royale games and playing them myself but
yeah that's uh let's try that again
yeah that's we'll run it back we'll run
it back and once I want with just one
kill hiding the whole game yeah that's
also very possible Bobo I mean if you
have like a good like we were pretty
fortunate with a circle that last game
because we were pretty much in the
middle of it like three three times in a
row until like we finally had to move
and I feel like if you get that one kill
already and like you kind of own that
area you have like the advantage right
so yeah there's a lot of luck in these
battle royale games even and um like I
played a lot of h1z1 king of the kill
and it's the same thing it's like you
know one is can you find the right loot
and two like are you gonna have to like
trek across the whole damn map yeah
which can be like depending on how you
react to the circle can definitely
affects like how far into the match that
you'll you'll make it
often times like when I'm playing the
squads with homies like we like to skirt
around the circle the hold yeah yeah
even in the early game it's like let's
just go around the edge of the circle so
you have to like so you have that to
your back yeah you know no one's gonna
be rolling up on you from behind yeah
number one I've uh I've watched ninja
play a little bit
I've watched like shroud and then play
to sew but still there's a lot of stuff
you have to learn in the game but thank
you for the tip there it is one of the
faster ways to learn I feel like
obviously playing is pretty good too but
like just seeing like high level play
and like some of their tactics just give
you a like a good baseline of like oh I
shouldn't be doing that like best
practices yeah exactly
Calvin you can convince Mary to play
these battle royale games she might be
good at it she's good at camping we used
to play Cod with a couple folks and we
always made fun of her because like she
she heard kill death ratio it's like
usually high but she's usually camping
and then we call her out for it but then
she's like I'm not camping but there's
like multiple like screenshots and
videos I've heard it's like in a corner
come on just just be honest it's alright
it's alright the cameras your effective
tactical camping you know it's fine
that's fine
it'll definitely work in a game like
this too because oh right yes this is
good this is good let's go art all right
let me gather some resources - I don't
think anyone else dropped near me but uh
can never be too old
um I lied no we good he got nothing dude
let's go let's go let's go yeah break
down that wall let's go home even doing
why is he helping you out this is a oh
man you better hope he run away which
this is a really poor showing of what I
am capable of you can shoot through
those like the holes oh yeah yeah that's
the collision detection makes it so that
what the hell you got you bro I hella go
oh he didn't get the shotgun though yeah
there's like no other weapons here so
you probably dipped out oh there is
always free
it's good Wow I haven't hit anything
he's not free oh I mean I think I think
I could do better than that was yes yeah
well I was a do that was a TI oh he's in
the house he might have a gun now
oh the old trusty shotgun Oh luckily you
got there before yeah I could have got I
could have got blowed up good so the
guns are already loaded when you pick
them up just like pop G where you have
to reload yep so that's one less thing
you have to worry about you gotta get
some AR ammo man yeah I know about a
ours comes in clutch but not now
although I don't know maybe after seeing
you shoot the gun maybe it's not so so
good oh that's stolen I don't want
stones ya know all right
I don't know why I went back to this
house cuz there's nothing here anymore
Yeah right now let me see what uh are
you in the circle that's good yeah I'm
in the circle so I don't have to worry
about running across the mat but I will
try and get to this town right here
moisty Meier yeah moist
all right run this way alright now y'all
can watch me run across grassy fields
for the next five minutes welcome to the
fun part of battle royale game so yeah
hey at least we got a kill in the first
like X amount of time granted it was
kind of a free kill that was almost
watched they saved don't hate dogs
hashtag save no I'm just telling it how
it is
it was almost botched your and then you
saved it you're right you're right I
mean yeah I'm kind of throwing you under
the bus a little bit and I probably
would have missed too but that's what I
get to do as the person that's not
playing the game do you everyone
everyone you bring on stream man I check
Nick crap old it doesn't feel good when
you're in the chair cuz I like it was
happening to me I was like playing Cod
the other day I was like oh shoot
whoa I heard it you heard it think semi
go squirt what's up Jason Bohn cutter
welcome to the stream hello oh look at
this look at this look at his what's go
cheap
oh man is that verbal shotgun yeah its
barrel shotgun I'll switch that out I
don't want that pump pump action poop oh
you just drop your shotgun oh whoa what
pro moves giveaway position I'm sorry I
don't know what it was
he didn't want anyone else have that
grenade yeah well I was gonna use it but
I don't want to leave it laying there
yeah yeah yeah think tactically
brilliant I need yes Jason we do what
Jason say oh this is a constant stream
of embarrassment man I was feeling good
I was strapped up with like well that's
because you like making the noises
breaking down walls you never feel safe
in these games and I felt I felt safe
and then that was that was the cause of
my downfall and that's okay you did
better than the zero kill one yeah
at least I'm racking up kills man I hope
hope y'all is finding this enlightening
for y'all people sound the man 1 0 to 8
says I started just start playing this
game and have no idea what I'm doing
it's really frustrating what kind of
addicting yeah I mean if you have the
personality to kind of just like weather
the storm and like you want to get
better I just you know obviously playing
the games gonna do that and the game
lends itself to you know you die just we
just died getting back right into it
jump back in so I mean one thing though
is that the looting phase in these
battle royale games can like wear you
down I know I definitely noticed that
playing on them like 100 hours of pub G
it's like do I feel like going through
the loot phase and obviously in
fortnight you have that phase as well
yeah it's not as I wouldn't say it says
like doesn't wear you down as much in
fortnight but like in pub G like I can
only play so much before I'm just like I
don't want to spend 10 minutes looting
to get gunned down in like one minute
from some flight and see him out in the
corner so that's like a that's something
you have to accept in these games but
once you do boy yeah I also think to
like the way you play which is like
mainly squad based probably helps kind
of like mitigate some of that yeah
but still yeah when we play pub G when
when me and Nick were on stream like and
we looted for like a good you know like
five to ten maybe even longer than that
you know like dwindling down to like 30
people or whatever and then dying
without getting kill it does feel bad
yeah like oh man I had like level three
vest level three helm had you know like
my scar my I'm playing with that you
know and just like well yeah I don't
want to do that again yeah I was talking
to Jimmy to homeboy Jimmy we work with
is that he was trying to get one of his
one of his friends into pub G and then
like Jimmy's into it he likes playing it
and but his his friend was just like I
don't get it like why do I spend ten
minutes trying to find items if I'm just
card attention though right because like
you're with somebody else you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I need to find gun any I
find a gun like yeah this for like when
I was playing I was like oh there's so
many people here after that I'm out of
here
I dipped out I went somewhere else I was
like I don't wanna I don't even want to
engage Terry Shipman says when you glide
down make sure you aim and push your
stick of what we bow ski board your
momentum counts as you fall oh yeah yeah
I'm gonna say yeah that's you oh I don't
know oh how about loot and how Oh
like if you see like the CICE a ton of
people here it's like maybe I want to
get into that let's get into it get
'spicy let's go let's let's play spicy I
like that
I mean I'm sweating now I don't know how
spicy I wa I can't handle the spice man
handle the 5x spice when I get want to
go gotta go mild yeah one when I got
curry like I got it go like 1 2 3
anything I like back in the day I could
like maybe this is just me and I don't
know if chat can agree or not like I
feel like years ago like the Taco Bell
mild sauce to me was more spicy than the
spicy - you better not let him get a
shotgun on you it's probably now I'm
dead I'm dead
thanks for watching y'all he does up
shotgun peace out dip on him no get some
range on him and show him your
blunderbuss Magnum abilities not a fight
you got out though I think you hit him
once right I hit him once for like 30 or
something but now I'm just like he got
booted out of my own house man it feels
bad he's looting in that house there was
yeah there was a chest in there too man
do you have a ps4 yeah we have a ton of
stores in the office but we're playing
on PC right now yeah yeah usually when
it comes to shooters I got a play PC I
don't think I would have got those five
kills that one I definitely would I'm
pretty sure I feel more confident
playing for a night ps4 if I had to
start I feel like I would there's a
green gun tier right let's chocolate I
definitely feel like I would excel more
there I will have better success early
on but I think that yeah if you want to
blue they are if you want to have or
sorry sniper if you want to have a
better time aiming PCs by the way I hear
some oh that's will had shields man good
why need to be spicy and you got spicy I
got out spicy twice oh that guy had
nothing that feels bad you're just like
standing there like that feels bad oh
man what are y'all playing on it's got a
1080i seven I think 7700
I think 32 gigs of RAM so it's a pretty
beefy PC yeah we're running smooth we're
only what is only a 10 how about how
about at 12 o'clock
you you try to teach me how to play like
half an hour we'll see how okay sure
y'all gotta stick around to see take at
whoops I'm gonna get a kill that's my
goal all right yeah if you got a killer
like Philanthropy aka or been Gingka and
the Office says mild border sauce is the
truth it's the only sauce that actually
tastes good this is Taco Bell talk I
don't actually can't heat Taco Bell
anymore it kind of like that's too old
huh doesn't agree with my stomach man I
can't can't do it man but uh remember
when GPUs were affordable yeah dude we
have a video piece you guys y'all did a
video piece or Jimmy did about why now
is not the time to buy I actually the
funny thing was I was actually starting
to look into some stuff for the office
and I was I all right let me go look at
GPU prices when I go look at a 1080 1080
TI 10 even 1070 just to see everything
we a lot of we have a lot
ten seventies in the office but I was
just curious right no it's like dude
everything that's fine everything is
gone and and we're like very very
expensive and it's because of that damn
crypto crypto game I know it's it's wild
man yes around with the crypto game
hella no I don't know I don't touch that
that's some high-level stuff my friend
probably would be at least a millionaire
not like multi-millionaire but a
millionaire if he had to held on to his
Bitcoin really well cuz the thing is he
it was like earlier this is like two
three years ago and he had it when like
it was just like a few hundred dollars
you know what I mean yeah but then he
had that really bad dip you know what I
mean like it dropped like a lot volatile
and it finally recovered and then he it
went up a little bit more and it was
kind of stable for a while and he was
just like you know what I had my fill I
want that money back
you know like or I want some profit and
like yeah turns out that was not the
move to do but I mean it's fine I mean
that's how all that crypto stuff works
it's got big swings like yeah one week
it'll be a little like a drop in value
like that last was a lot two weeks ago
or last week when every like crypto
dropped like thirty percent or something
crazy it's like everything tanked but
now I think bitcoins like back to eleven
twelve K which is still insane this is
beyond me man I don't I don't want it I
don't want to think about that stuff
because or like what the reason why I'm
not there's like three fools over here
you can play mouse keyboard on ps4 just
plug it in yeah I feel like that's
unfair though man I mean I know it's I
know it's part of the capability but
like dude mouse keyboard should always
you know it's be a like I you know
double stick controller situation
lagging here a little bit what the hell
was that green or is that just you
jumping and then legs open you sure I
hear a chest somewhere I hear - oh man
I'm Oh y'all servers is mmm yeah I got
do some about your servers well how old
is how uh how was when you're playing
how bad was it
I mean it was fine up till now so yeah
this is probably the first at least for
today this feels
Oh what the hell I'll see I was trying
to quit
you have to left click after 5 or just
oh yeah you do yeah okay poke gee this
game is a rip ah it's free though good
Oh with a scope with the scope dama
there to you in the corner if you need
it
oh yeah sure thanks man okay yeah this
oh hey it's not Reggie no register Hey
yeah I saw it yeah those y'all saw below
9k good to know yeah I saw that
that was awkward yeah I'm gonna play
around the game yeah
he saw his crosshair everyone saw his
car so you'll see in a second yeah man
I'm relying on my CS skills right now so
dude it's not even come sure yeah hey
I'm gonna be relying on my destiny
skills then sure what's what skills you
need a destiny dog I'm just kidding I'm
not trying to hate I appreciate he's
gonna hate players no play they I
appreciate you dog so yeah thanks
everyone again for tuning in and and
helping us out a little bit with four
nights it's kind of our one say
necessarily gave us first dive into the
Battle Royale but definitely our first
time live that's for sure
yeah it's good to get a fresh
perspective from some way that's just
played like 10 hours I've only really
watched I'm gonna try to play in like 15
minutes for like half an hour see how
that goes if it gets like if I die like
a lot I'm going to switch back or just
call it a day you know ain't no thing I
believe in you though all right Lord you
believe in me sometimes I don't believe
in me but then sometimes things work out
that's that's that's all of us man see
all right yeah I think that people are
starting to well when fortnight went
Battle Royale that kind of already it
had legs under it because it was on
consoles and it's free but there's
there's been a wave of like popularity I
think at least from what I seen cuz when
I log into PSN like a bunch of my homies
yeah I guess it's free yeah because
that's like a huge
draw it's like you can just hop in and
try it play if you like it cool and then
like you know if your friends are
playing cool well I should caveat that
by saying you probably need PS plus or
PS gold but yeah you do but I mean y'all
are trash I don't know about that
Fernando we got my kill just now we got
seven place you want to rewind that
stream just a little bit right yeah you
know you know I'm saying also that yeah
I have to agree with you in that
scenario that'd be the hit markers were
not registering there so yeah usually
usually I just blame everything on ps4
instead PC players to get well we good
we good we bout to show you that this
guy right here to our red in front of
you don't die you're done son done we
gonna follow him and he's um he's a Mary
Poppins little thing that he's got good
looking ass let's go alright alright
hopefully we get some some reg and we
also get guns look like it's lagging
like it was just now but we'll see mmm
I'm not making up items right away so
there's no like indicator on your
latency right nope I don't have a ping
count or anything like that there some
traps it's a trap Oh shield is good come
on pick it up alright yeah okay what I
can do is we can try another ethernet
port and see how that goes yeah we was
good though earlier so I don't know well
still I can give you a faster Ethernet
port potentially okay whoa probably the
the cord I'll get that set up I'm gonna
get that set up just spray paint yeah
I'll fix it on all right I'm not trying
to make excuses but I am trying to make
excuses so man sorry that y'all didn't
get a good showing there but this is
what you're gonna have to do though is
you're gonna have to back out okay
yeah it's fine and I got to go full
camera real quick alright why don't you
fix that for a second here take that guy
and unplug that other guy and we should
be good
no oh you got a yeah okay gotcha
see if it's smart enough to just pick
back up or we actually have to reload
let you just go back in or is it it's
weird because I would have assumed it
would just boot you but I can try and
hop in
that's really cool
all right I'll go buy that we'll see if
that goes I like right now we're in
business now I'm gonna show y'all what
it's like to get a fortnight you can
talk about setting yourself up I know
setting y'all up for disappointment
psyche so you always want to want to set
expectations low but overperform and
that's yeah are you doing smart smart
that's what that's what I thought about
Jumanji then the last you mangy movie
thought it was gonna be not that great
turned out to be pretty good time yeah
just set your expectations low uh just
your row saying holy crap everyone is
playing this game now no one's playing
any other game crazy how big this game
got yeah well part of it is because it's
like as mentioned it's free now for a
lot of people to play sans you know
having PlayStation Plus and you know
Xbox I love that but there's there's
still definitely a handful of other
games are being played poki still gets
played obviously yeah Pub Gees still top
and Steam concurrent players I've been
I've been playing a lot of that Monster
Hunter I've been hunting them dragons so
Dragon Ball fighters just came out
Dragonball Fighters is dope too a lot of
good stuff out yeah you think you think
of January as like a slow time for games
but I think companies are slowly
realizing that like January February
even though I understand it's like a lot
of people spend their money during like
Christmas stuff like that so like it's a
prior harder time to try to sell a game
but I feel like since it's so dead and
move like the first quarter usually that
like that February early February late
January
is actually pretty good time to come out
the game because you shouldn't have too
much competition yeah oh man that's all
that's all I think it's good luck to you
and this like all this is like three
different stories going on here oh I see
some perp all I'm gonna get to it before
this day I don't know what it is odds
the trap get trapped so Launchpad birds
in the [ __ ] seeing Brian alright
alright let's go how's it now it's uh
it's fine it's cool wait is it I I think
it's okay alright cool
that was man i'm you get for like just
smacking i don't know why you're
smacking stuff break right off the bat
man kill this dude you didn't even see
you man i'm really i really fell off man
you really did fall off
smack die you got you got one more
chance before I take over okay yeah I
think that's fair yeah okay take air
quotes take over like like I'm gonna do
any better send the bar low good so then
when I come roll up yeah hey look good
what a good friend Oh y'all y'all tuning
in right now you probably missed out on
that one time we we got in top ten but
uh Graeme gray haze gamespot going to
end soon what does that even mean no we
good unless you mean end the stream
we're not ending that we're gonna
streaming like I don't 30 minutes
getting all right let's try this again
thanks thanks for sticking around guy I
know I don't know those three people
landed there precedes the Chow Fox
hey you like swinging the pickaxe man
what can I say yeah that was that was
probably not the best so what you'll get
one from my gameplay is safer gameplay
okay but probably crap your aim so
there's a trade on now there's a trade
off so you won't see anything like that
happened but you know yeah I mean you
play too much destiny you rely on that
auto aim too much I play PC too okay I'm
there to infinity beats you know are a
lot you didn't watch the first half of
this dream when he was actually in
Merkin fools so alright it is what it is
that uh you know there haven't been too
many kills but the last two matches has
been had been a pretty laggy so we just
switched Ethernet ports here it was
definitely the line
it's fine now you can actually watch it
there's like you just watch the
crosshair no bullet protection or no hit
markers or anything yeah all right now
I'm gonna try don't worry if you thought
his gameplay was riveting wait till the
the first timer here gives it a shot and
shows you what's up alright I'll try and
get back to what I was used to doing
which is murdering fools male ok my bad
I thought you're gonna tell me breaking
boxes
oh no that yeah that was if y'all if
y'all in the chat want to judge me for
the way I played those last two matches
it's fine I know that well no I agree -
that was really bad I called him out for
it man I called him out I was like
there's no like if you're chopping like
if you're chopping it up to get to a
chest or to get into a building I
thought yeah ok that makes some tactical
sense but you're like giving away your
position not doing anything really not
getting any items like why no bolt
action not really thinking leaving doors
open I've always I am puggsy I left the
doors open like I just said f it pick it
up pick it up alright there we go I hear
a chess come back and battering of guns
which is good so I hear the chest - yeah
[Music]
I'm trying to listen for where it was
but that's just oh my god wait I hear
tell aloud maybe it's back here oh it's
in the dog dog house yeah I'll talk
basing all that right here get some
Bandos it's all good
there's amel under the stairs if you
move it but girls
that's what to infinity said hmm thank
you I I really appreciate y'all like who
are looking out for stuff like yeah ammo
items I'm probably switch answer bear
says glad you guys are cool and taking a
stride a lot of hate when putting your
game plan on the internet yeah I mean it
happens it's fine it's I will also admit
though because like as a viewer I
understand the frustration like I get it
but you know I'm gonna give it to
Michael that like as an overall if we
throw out those two lagging matches if
we throw those two out like on the whole
his average is actually like pretty
decent you know what I mean like and
that's all you can expect right we never
said we were we were pro for night
gamers you know Michael's got 10 to 12
ish hours playing solo and I'm about to
hop in in a second here yeah I think
probably I'm yeah with like no
experience and barely ever playing pub G
so it should be a hoot and a holler for
you guys you guys gonna trash on me all
you want my goal is to get a kill I hope
you all support me someone is saying at
the top of the house but it was at the
dog house so no Oh unless there's
another one up there I don't know
probably I'm not paying attention that
long shots popping off turn up the audio
for you okay someone just died so I
would assume that guy killed them Oh
gunshots over here that's nice to the
right now I maybe my headphones is
backwards no oh my god oh my god not
that good I'd only give me a 25 what I
don't want I don't want that I don't
want needs I like that I like the no
reload BS though like I every time like
you drop a gun or pick up a gun like
just like man this sucks I hear it it
might be upstairs I haven't been I have
a bit building much minutes on the roof
oh yo there's a fool in there
let's go Chi it's got it said now you
got shotgun I got played dude I got
hella played all right so if y'all want
to hit on me it's all good but wait till
you watched a play cuz I'll make you
look good and I'm real booty probably
man you look free right there you just
like ran up you know no problem all
right
oh do your mouse sensitivities hella
slow yeah I always play low sensitivity
that's that's that's that's them CS days
man I gotta turn it up turn up let's
turn up man oh there you go that's
that's welcome everyone that's good
that's good how do you know I do like
nowadays it's all about like being able
to like turn hella fast and [ __ ] no nah
man I gotta get them long strides those
Long's swipes to be accurate so I don't
know it's just scary wish me luck
I don't know half of what's going on
here place hash place 847 Tico's over
under it's definitely under well
actually if you just camp out and no I'm
tryna I'll try to I'll try to like fight
but like I'm not gonna like all right so
this is this that's one stop trying to
instigate GUP
oh there's no Crouch huh or is there
Cutler's crowd it's it's a control
there's no prone though okay yeah not
that you really would really need to
prone in this game so yeah well I hey
I'm do that
what's good everyone whoa-ho Smigel hi
oh here here with Eric Tay yeah we're
watching first timer first timer right
here that's actually hit let's try and
help them out though
let's support our friends I see I'll try
to play spicy you'll see how bad the
first round goes Yosef where do i well
where is it good no we over here
anywhere that's a it's a town really
I mean salty springs tilted Towers
that's deep Oh it'll feel i think retail
road was where i was at last time that
place is real spicy how about we go to
like where do you think where does it
usually where does the circle usually
whatever never know what that's that's
the engine we're going there whatever
they had towers oh shoot that's hella
far no we go on to this right here
salty springs for all y'all that got too
much oh no you know Oh get over it
you'll you'll whoop um just make sure
you strapped up real quick make sure I
hit boxes outside right no don't do that
unless you really wanna do drop note why
alright just start start swinging start
swinging all that blue close a door on
you throw hands boy throw pickaxes
alright I feel like I was winning keep
it up keep it up you're good you're
doing alright under looks our YouTube
dude how oh yeah we'll buy you hmm
I shoulda just ran and got a gun alright
well over under there we just laugh nah
I'll give you a couple more tries to get
over 47 damn bonus if I was dumb that
was so dumb that was yeah no it's all
right at the point I thought I was
winning cuz I was like looking at his
life I was like dude I think I'm winning
and then he started like warming up
warming up those swings so yeah that's
the same as throwing hands in puff gee I
think that it's like luck of the draw
well that's like slower though it is it
is slower I mean like when you miss you
miss yeah you headshot punching alright
real real stuff right now alright
alright well our goal is to try to at
least get higher than oh I should pick
up a gun
it's either with the aiming and stuff
one kill or higher than 47 or both or
both I'm going
for both I'm waiting for Booker that's
that's gonna be the that's the goal yeah
and everyone in chat if you wanna if you
want a backseat game it's all good you
know you can pick up on things we might
miss cuz when you're when you play in
this on stream and it's very has this
tactic work that works in in destiny of
the old Yule cow tall dolphin diving
what wait you can't Crouch known another
Crouch aim so then like I just kind of
like what dolphin diving was a
battlefield - if y'all played
battlefield 2 back in the demo go back
to the salty spring says I'm salty
I'm salt Atlas salty man I'm so salty
too old for that much sodium dog man I'm
all about sodium love the salts and I
don't hydrate enough either so it's like
it's even worse ok let's let's be on the
lookout for some ammo weapons that might
you can't see in your peripheral vision
othing over 40 cent I I will try to uh
over 47 with with one oh my god that
guy's dropping so much faster that's
alright bull in here you know you could
take them on dude there are they're
already so he's what - swinging the axe
alright that guy's on top of the house
he's flowing his way in that oh that
guy's in this house
let's go to this house look how fast
that is alright there you go you got
your own carve out your own section I
hear you're a chest as well so we might
might get lucky here with some items
yeah or okay come on there you go let's
see what let's see what's in the box a
blue assault rifle alright you're good
you can can engage with that I hear
another here another chest maybe it's
across that wall I don't have too much
look oh there yeah let's - três let's go
I'm good at looter looting games Michael
you didn't know that
yeah today's all about them looting game
monster hunter destiny - Diablo
jam exactly I'm all about that loot life
we playing the ridge here oh [ __ ] there
on that side huh maybe yeah but well the
town is
town is that way so I know but like no
we in the circle calling it circle
you're you're you're in good hands
I hear you're something I heared some
light going on I hear someone strapping
up around you oh I hear a shotgun
someone got the pump
I don't shells in the phone that's not
good how good is hipfire it fires fine
I think that's oh let's get it let's get
it let's see how good is hit by this all
there's someone else too there's there's
two fools going at it so yeah you're
even spotted so oh there it is oh man so
I'm not a very good announcer I just
wanted you to concentrate I know I tried
I didn't I didn't want to put too much
pressure on you but uh what you could
have had a kill what you did it so the
show goes on at the I meant the same
boat leaving a guy at 30 life you're
about to get rekt I just get get ready
yo I hope you I don't even know how to
organize my loot I'm just picking stuff
up yeah this is no real right so dare
you loot so in that case would you have
hip fired more I ate yes a lot in games
I feel like I 80s too much of it well it
depends like in that situation I don't
think 80s I also I was feathering it a
lot should I have just been spraying to
spray
yeah just brave is that kind of game
exactly yeah this is it plays closer to
an arena shooter it's cute all right so
you know there's still like bullet drop
with the sniper rifles too but we'll
cross that bridge when we guns that out
yet just so you guys know yeah that
patch has been delayed according to epic
or it's delayed yeah until they figure
it out all right but in the meantime
so do you were you aiming the shotgun
yes but I mean if they're like super
close I don't think it's it's not
entirely necessary
come on man I need some practice these
matches seem though
all right we're not alone again then
love me the springs what can I say
all right let's just seem to start
faster than pub G matches yeah I think
seems to be the case so you can jump in
and out a lot faster guns are pressing
right thank you
all right let's support support our boy
Tay here so make sure that he no support
comes until I get a kill
we got a shooter hey you're not even
dropping in the place you marked nope
I'm not
oh no yeah I'm gonna go to this Shack
and then I'm gonna go to the salties I
think there's a chest in there is oh I
know I was a tree I thought it was
glowing I wish I need glasses dawg
do you yup I lost them I went to an
event and I left them on top of a boxes
no and I was like well that sounds
horrible and got those no more oh you
got some potion sippin on that potion
also I hear I hear a chest - oh yeah I
think maybe I'm tripping
might be on the second or maybe it's no
maybe it's an attic oh it's up there but
how do I probably good you can build it
build stairs press f3 and then construct
that construct oh there ya go see you're
picking up on some basics on on the job
Hey oh you got an assault rifle with a
skull that's that good good there you go
and you got armor alright
yeah you just drag and drop it there
there you go thank you for the tip I
could've told I knew that I just don't
want to tell you yeah like I learned
yourself a circle there you go you're in
it cool we should uh that's what's up go
to tilt the towers I guess how important
is the serpentine I guess yeah it could
help you run faster with the pick out or
now I don't know let's go you know how
like like you run faster with a knife in
now yeah
I just moved that mouse at all yeah
all right like cuz like you run faster
and pop G without anything right yeah
but you can't unequip everything
entirely and in fortnight but I don't
know if you run faster with your pickaxe
out I don't imagine it's [ __ ]
I imagine doesn't affect you running
speed all that much if anyone the chat
knows for sure definitely let us know
someone's already
yeah somes got some long range stuff on
them already another assault rifle
duster so yeah if you 80s with this
obviously want to build even though
that's part of the game
yeah if you want to get up this this
Hill man just build someone that you I
found those upstairs a normal person's
way ooh
loot cave yeah okay you know all about
loot caves don't you I do
there's Q switch weapons Q switches to
construction so then if you yeah if you
hit Q so you have to manually manually
switch oh you can know about this scope
though man
what about it I'm not feeling it now for
you looking for x yeah I know I'm more
of a 2 x Red Dot hollow kind of guy you
know I feel you on that all there's
someone's already built up a long ass
staircase there so you better watch out
I hear a chest though yeah there's also
a chest giving off some sound might be
might be upstairs I don't want to say
for sure maybe you can get on that
staircase over there and see what lies
ahead apply someone with a shotgun it's
gonna blast you
oh it's some building here man you're
already a pro don't destroy your own
stairs brick takes a long-ass time to
yeah yeah so there's it's a fact machine
test that might be on the third floor
the fourth floor I still get that chess
yeah
Oh someone has already busted up in here
and built their own stairs they did not
get the chest then yeah yeah oh that was
hella close who that where he had to
wear a hat no they took the ammo Oh
oh here we go we got some action right
here oh that hella hurt no no that was a
good shot you don't want to go toe to
toe with someone with a real a sniper
rifle
oh you if you if you move you're gonna
stop healing so yeah legit bro still got
a shield potion so check out the world
50 you'll get over it
shield and like 40 life song you can use
another shield potion if you want hey I
got 41 though oh yeah okay well he says
that can I get a kill cam can I get a
headshot oh my god Dan you got opt man
straight oh no I got the building yeah
so that wasn't too bad you got the hang
of building stairs to get up hires or
its build off of that turns out there's
a there's a pretty high ceiling for how
good players can be mm-hmm
I'll bet you though like I told you
before stream I bet you if we fired up
ps4 though I'd be killing okay you know
believe me I bet I could take you one on
one console probably yeah I don't really
play shooters on comm you see is another
story like I don't I win I wouldn't pick
myself for PC but you know maybe if next
time we do a fortnight stream we can get
the console version up in here and you
can show us quote-unquote yeah I guess
so
and I don't know maybe we'll have better
luck that time well we still got some
time yeah we got time here so the wait
at the rate I'm going at least two more
matches in yeah like I said my goal was
to get one kill well there was two goals
to get top about 47 so we achieved that
keep an unlocked and now the next goal
is get at least one kill which I think
you can do man not you're not trash I
mean you're like you're pretty trash but
you're not that yeah I'm not like bottom
with the wrong trash just like just like
man that's all right I had the drop I
should have tried it headshot him but
you know at this point I was just like
hit markers are good why should a new
after he sniped me that one time that
you should buy pretty good snipers that
I probably wasn't gonna be able to take
him if I would have been better it's
like just my favorite are salty springs
now we're in the circle I could just
chill it didn't look like he was gonna
come after me like unless I peeked you
know yeah [ __ ] I'm held over from the
thing maybe we're not gonna get too
salty springs oh oh you'll get there
that it yeah especially when you
parachute so ubi oh boy this is uh this
is fine I'm I'm having fun watching you
get you a dry well yeah there's a one
guy struggles real I don't see anyone
else though maybe you can oh we got two
got two perps two perpetrators but you
have to jump on the loop phase so I
think I hear someone else using swinging
their pickaxe they've gotten really
close by maybe they're on the top floor
or something no that's weird
well at least we got something we got
some shields we got an SMG we're okay
shape for they won't know that I'm here
right
nope this is this is some some pub G
play if you just want to camp in that
corner no that was just to get the
shield off camping some bathtubs they
won't know man yeah and I think oh you
know they haven't op why I'm nervous oh
yeah see oh
oh no you don't want to go against you
don't want to go against an assault
rifle I don't know not with an SMG it's
not like pop G or it's like kind of fair
UMP and pop G it's really good but smg's
in this game not so much unless someone
in the chat thinks otherwise close the
door behind you now now we don't care
come at us
it's bait for baiting them with open
doors oh there's a blue over in that
other building come from he was uh oh
you see that's that's that next level
stuff you uh you know at that next level
man eye level right now what do you say
to people who don't like blood-borne or
Dark Souls what you got a good get good
yeah good that's to always close the
door it didn't matter if I closed the
door there because he just made his own
door to me yeah in for tonight like it's
not it's not necessarily about well the
way you get the jump on people in for
night it's very different like he did
there like he's on the second floor I'm
not gonna go through the doors I'm gonna
build my own staircase in Florida and
then he'll break down the wall that he's
hiding behind just small stuff like that
really I think this helps for a night
separate itself in pub Jean yeah it's
that next level meta yeah past the
normal battle royale stuff alright still
looking for that one kill pretty decent
about it I just need to get a shotgun
and run into someone and then we just
hope for the best that is that is what
that's the plan
you can't really uh can't rely on
finding a specific weapon you know this
game make it happen you got to make do
with whatever you get all right what
place y'all in the chat work what place
you think today's gonna get in this
match right here
I say 45 depending on what you say I
could just camp it harder hey man I I'm
all for that if try a new area which I a
new area maybe retail row would treat us
a little bit better
retail rows trash I think it's where the
burger shop is kind of hungry
well I'm hella far from there I don't
know if we're gonna make that you wants
you to deploy your glider you can you
can you can cover a lot of ground and in
the drop phase in fortnight like the
glider can lolly goes definitely too on
their way three on their way nope mmm
too much spice dude there's like six
people going there I'm gonna go to this
little shack and hope for the best too
much sauce oh there's a guy over there
it's a ya you better hope you got some
long-range weapons in that that little
shack right there there's a chest so
maybe we'll get lucky with an assault
rifle I fall any slower
no there's an ER right there there's an
air burst I don't like the burst rifle
in this game but it can be effective if
you're if you're into that sort of thing
already popping shields alright we're in
shape every advantage I could possibly
get oh another green Oh Otto shoddy
oh now you're in business dawg I got a
little shield you got your shotgun got a
AR I'm feeling good about this one I
feel good can we not get out now you
gotta break that down let's break it
down oh you're you're playing a little
spicy you're the one apprehensive over
here I want to give people what they
want to see either a quick death or a
quick kick quick kill although you said
what did you say 41 I said 45 watch
let's go
he waited me out he waited me out cuz he
was also Lauren Han I wasn't that low
damn or we could gotta get a shotgun
it's over
oh that's Otto Shahi - huh yep they're
shooting it like a pump-action man just
ice it out the AR I should just like or
well you could we could have done is uh
build stairs to give him the second
floor and then surprise him by jump yeah
I gotta get the jump that guy was a pro
no I wasn't
now who you're watchin really on spur oh
no definitely not he definitely baited
me and I cuz he stopped jumping he
waited for me to jump and then he murked
me once I jumped yeah yeah yeah
that's all right now you don't think so
you don't think that's what he did
maybe that's what he did I don't know if
he deliberately thought about that or
maybe he did not giving him credit
ain't nobody getting credit on this
dream unless you win all right
or if you got more than five kills so
seven he called it it wasn't seven he
was it I thought it was worse than that
your place is just now yeah oh I don't
know now here we go my goal is still one
kill and I'm gonna get it because I feel
like it's like a momentum you know you
get that first kill yeah you just keep
getting them you know yeah I definitely
felt that in my one match I did pretty
alright in can't put I haven't really
messed around with traps all that much
you can do some really really cool
things with traps but I'm not on that
level like if I find a trap I'll just
throw it down where I think someone will
walk there to use slurp it up he bagged
that purple train all right all right
what do you where do you think I should
go not moisty Mayer okay you should go
too
we're coming the opposite way uh do you
want to go somewhere like pretty open or
do you want to coach where I go coach
all right go try and get to uh go to
till two towers oh wow a jump straight
up all you already deployed your
parachute yeah get try and get into
tilted towers some lion game that place
looks wild dude it I think there's a
hell of people going there so it's gonna
be real spicy and I have oh it is it is
hella spicy no that's that talk about
fire sauce over there boy I'll go find
them in a second
hopefully this is like gas station over
here you got something
gas dump shouty if they don't have
nothing at the gas station oh there's a
chest I think oh no there isn't there's
some wood there's some bandages the log
time for this again the cars vehicles
now okay really dossier dossier that's
that that's that tactical stuff and pub
to you you know you ain't got that here
you gotta get on your own two feet man
yeah where's the door food I think
that's one of the things I don't like
about fortnight is traversing across
like open fields because just you know
part of the fun in pub she's like cause
their vehicle can I get everyone in
vehicle and let's like get into a
tactical position but here it's like
you've got a run this is a poor choice
you're an open field with a shotgun yeah
you'll get over it
it'll be fine oh man all right what
place chat if you all want to chime in
what place you think we're gonna get
here about to show them some pro camping
together that high place if you're gonna
say that I'm not gonna get it's all good
hey if you played so in the towers
plates well I'm just gonna play I'm a
loop stuff and then die with all that we
that's like we said earlier man that's
that's a big part of these battle royale
games is like looting and then getting
shot up and losing all the damn loot
that you had sometimes like and it gets
really frustrated especially in I do too
is that you got like just got like armor
you got guns oh all this good stuff and
then you know sometimes you just get it
merked yeah just get merthin it's like
wow great I even get a I had two hundred
five five six bullets and I decked out
and I think I had that one game I was
like well and you didn't get it get a
shot off oh my gosh shot off
no actually sometimes they roll up on
you and you're just like well what you
gonna do yeah happens man that's that's
just the risk you have to take when you
play these types of games
oh we taking risks right now all right
cool yeah check this checked back out
here remember there was like six or
seven people that drop there's a towers
yeah you only got a shotgun to just
blank gun to nothing for you just leave
that in there anybody care I care 62
this time that's a good summary of the
products pretty good part of the game is
it's not getting killed
oh is it Chesapeake or yeah there's
chests somewhere here behind this car oh
and the trunk trunk pops let's get it
I feel good about this one I believe in
you oh shoot
so you can just chill like since tilted
towers is right at the edge of the
circle I mean I'm not saying you should
do this but you could wait for the
circle to converge and then just like
chill on the outskirts of tilted towers
you give them pop G strats huh yeah
that's just that's how you play that's
how I play Club G at least if I'm not
like in the data center here that I did
there still I imagine there's still a
lot of people here oh yeah I see that
full up they're building his own his own
damn house yeah III think like what oh
he's right they're all not even paying
attention that that's what that's on
both of us I should I should uh I should
have helped you out with that I was like
oh look I got a trap thing you're like
hey there's a new don't like what it
went tight if you pulled the trap and
then it actually like killed up I just
we're trying man if y'all young this is
legit the last night you scared me just
now and then I got shotgun I was like
[ __ ] baby sharp a shotgun me through
shield you had one shot at me you one
shot at me yeah I think so you don't
think so you think he held it down let's
let's uh let's run the replay on that
one I'm pretty sure he like one shot me
with a shotgun through my shield we're
gonna have to review that I never heard
another shot I'd only heard one shot cuz
I got I got scared like that and then I
couldn't even like react to do anything
cuz I was just dead my bad dawg
that's all good I shouldn't even try I
always like oh I should try to like do
what that guys doing I'm like you know
like build up top why can't I build you
got no resources resources the open area
though I know you can't they don't let
you gather resources that's that's the
one thing that I think takes the most
practices like trying to pull off those
walls and stairs real quick alright
let's make it good this is the last one
I feel good here we just need to get
that one kid gotta like six games in me
I just kill not even afraid you can't
even do it I know I'm turning heel on
you where we going turn heel you're
gonna send me to a bad place tonight
yeah let's eat ours go
just go to dusty-ass and that's the ass
beat ball
where's dusty Deepa that's right a dead
ass maybe I don't know I don't now what
God does to people okay
all right this is it dusty Depot is
gonna be a where tazed last time my last
hand yeah
the last Alamo and the stream get a kill
tune in that's I don't know man I can do
it in poachy
I can't do it in fournette apparently I
can only do it on console I'm a console
console casual keep saying that but
we'll see
constable casual right here maybe maybe
next week we could do some ps4 fortnight
no no this is your chance to get a kill
man this is it
is there a way to like fall faster this
is it this is his chance
I think side oh he's got a gun
you better call something in there yo he
got a oh this is our IP alright detail
just just die dogs you're you're holding
on there you go it's just holding off
you know inevitable I think we still
have one more yeah dude that was wack
that's hella way yeah look like what am
I suppose they're like oh yeah sometimes
there's just nothing you can do okay so
would you I just ran there instead of
trying to swing at them yeah I was like
an SMG on like pass me yeah there's
especially when there's when someone has
a gun and you don't have a gun there's
there's no way you're gonna win that you
just got really bad my name you see my
name you know I saw your name earlier
with that AR mmm this games a lot harder
than I thought it was because I was
giving Michael all this stuff it's easy
to backseat game now I'm living the
reality yeah although I've also in most
cases been putting myself in bats
there's only the one time where I felt
pretty comfortable and the guy sniped me
cuz like that guy was like actually
legit good yeah you were strapped up
with some some good stuff to it some
good stuff that time but it's alright I
took the other gun yeah shoot me Oh dope
outfit hands hit dance done how did you
dance I hit something
I think was like seven no it was like F
how do you say like after seven no no I
did something I don't know how you did
it because I just imagine I just
panicked then like slap my hand on the
keyboard on accident alright doesn't
matter how bad it gets
alright let's uh every way I cook
appreciate it
everyone in the chat let's support our
boy give me your energy
Goku need your energy please channel it
all right let's go super saiyan on these
fools
it's Nobby shores sloppy shores maybe
but you don't wanna be too far out right
yeah
no you never know what these games man
this is so my god
oh no this I don't I don't feel so good
about this one
I don't know take it back there's
totally a guy that's like right there
this is your chance man I'm gonna die so
there's no way to go faster here right I
think if you move side to side like like
that smashing watching strafe Keys if
you just glide forward and stuff like
you'll you'll drop a little faster oh
look it's the pool ain't no water in
there oh I hear a chest - mm-hmm well
you think it's in the pool oh I don't
know about that I don't think so okay at
least we got what is what the hell is
this I don't think I've ever used that
before a little like little nail gun
looking thing it's full auto so you
should at least know that oh that scared
me I was like a shadow cool but it was
nothing okay what is that oh oh let's
ball up okay you wanna play basketball
yeah let's go oh we should we should
ball up we should ball up on stream and
I'm also I'm not dumb enough to get like
get dunked on yeah never if you see
someone you just best move out the way
mm-hmm there's a soccer field in there
too I think there might be a chest in
the middle that soccer field oh this is
it this is it this is it this is not it
no no no all right we got it we got to
go one more that one more okay yeah yeah
oh is this so sad people in chat are
thirsty first it's depressing oh man I
feel depressed
there's gonna be an update today Lin
they said it's delayed and there was no
ETA we're Peyronie's riperoni pepperonis
what's this
that's the locker I don't have anything
unlock this is my alt account so your
troll account yeah shameful yeah turns
out the shotgun doesn't do that much
damage there I just got lit up like
Christmas tree oh wow
stick to the fully auto guns yeah I
should I should I should just kept that
use that green whatever the hell that
thing was this thing this is it this is
it this is the round you get a kill feel
it yeah but it does like it feels like
like ppps damage yeah
PP shooter then that's how you die about
the pickaxe only does like ten damage
per hit and I feel I feel real bad it's
not gonna get any better to be honest I
should just go to junk Junction and hope
no one goes because you're I should go
to moisty mire and hopefully no one goes
there - yeah maybe maybe you can just
lake what about late this is what you do
so like what people do to like wrack up
kills is just wait till the very last
moment and this probably F K's is gonna
drop that's how you get your first kill
man that's how you got do it ROH kills
kill man retail roll is how we're gonna
go I say you go to moisty Meijer and
play a little moist keep it safe sure
until you see ten other people drop
their
okay fine that's all right let's say you
can drop like directly under it so you
can get that the fastest way down but
you know be fine
I don't think there's anyone else
rolling up no one wants to go to the
moist oh oh there's at least one this
this area seems pretty dense there's a
lot of areas we can get a good gun to
protect ourselves protect your neck what
is that well it's an AR a green AR Rob
tomato I should have really looked at
where that guy went to ANSI man you got
a dude I have not gotten a kill what do
you expect hella aunty is that on those
stairs no but I do hear it it might be
on the second floor okay I'm confident
here that this is this is the moment
just I don't think that's the play I
don't think that's a oh that's a boy so
he's gonna wreak some fools right now
Trust trust don't you do you think it's
Oh Todd maybe it's behind one of the
walls
oh yeah Barbro yeah it's all right
that's good some more ammo some bad
we're going away hearing it but I don't
know where it's just keep getting ammo
if it could be all right green AR is not
bad but you could use some shields
little purp suppressed pistol never
shall we be moving not right now maybe
in a minute because yeah that circle
doesn't converge all that fast at first
so you should be you be you'll be okay
cool I'm uh I'm getting nervous just
watching you oh oh yeah yeah there ain't
nothing in there we got some vandals
there you go you got it shotgun oh
you're gonna want to drop something for
you oh there it is
whoo we did it we got a guy that didn't
see me ah feels good it feels good
what's he gotta do what can I say the
streams over guys they should complete
mission completely that guy didn't even
put up a fight achievement unlocked till
you got his first kill in fortnight I
did it
he was like doing nothing there's a
chest on the truck I ain't got time for
that now you got too late sorry I missed
it that's my fault
I gotta get to the Waypoint my palms are
sweaty mom's sphaghetti yeah I feel it
it could oh no oh no what if it's
slanted you'll just slide okay you'll be
all right
you got no resources to build well you
have some brick but brick takes a little
bit longer to build up what is the
fastest but salty may be fatal fields
mule can skirt the fatal fields girl's
skirt just go salt ice salt a Springs
all right yep I'll just end the stream
or get a kill link you might win this
match dude okay yeah that's great what
someone that was exciting I don't know
about that the guy like literally looked
surprised and never shot at me well it's
more exciting than getting getting your
ass smoked yeah I suppose that's true
okay well I think we're in a pretty good
position now oh all right you like you
should stay there you can always make
some moves always got to be making moves
remember that y'all always making moves
I don't give her some shield is what I'm
like yeah she'll be could probably help
big time maybe you can start swinging
your axe out and open yeah some
resources you know that's what uh
because I really
build a lot yeah that's true with that
let's focus on not shotgun don't need
that use a few more shells maybe no
shells in the field I wonder I want to
get another easy kill that'd be nice
kills a kill man I'm not I'm not gonna
judge I'm Li a judge storm I shrink and
man we haven't gotten too well we'll
only one time we went into the late game
but when you he gets a late game the the
circle like it's dark man cuz it yeah
it's like a storm like a legit storm
going on so it feel it feels pretty
intense
it looks intense when you make it that
far but I don't if you'll ever make it
that far
wow I could I mean in theory you could
you could kind of force it a little bit
if you just chill but yeah definitely
I'm mainly looking for shield right now
though mood in hand or no it's laundry
you want to do or do you want to keep
trying to find some more loot trying to
get some shield here bro yeah let's kind
of get over blue let's keep moving
I figure if I keep moving they won't
find me I don't know if that's true at
all but I mean keep keep the momentum
going
no I'm sure you feel good about this
match right I'm 35 right now sure oh
dude
let's get it let's get it oh yes
Blu sniper my aro you don't drop that
there's only one bullet to and that's my
career all right most so bad
two kills man that's I'm telling you
it's about riding that momentum you know
it's twice as many as you as any time
yeah but that one at least felt
legitimate you know like so I could say
like there's a fair fight don't try and
play it down you got two kills man oh
okay
we're we're in business we're gonna ride
I have such [ __ ] awareness dude yeah I
like barely saw that person like until
like either you said something or I was
just like oh that's a person I don't
maybe cuz everything kind of looks the
same kind of blends into the background
yeah just not used to like looking for
people I guess yeah that's fine you'll
get you'll get good we'll get used to it
I need some shield though you probably
want to get across that bridge there
might be some stuff over there well you
want to take a long way around or you
can build your own staircase to get up
there I have no wood remember
oh yeah 45 wood oh do i okay I don't
know if that's enough to build an entire
staircase to get over the bridge but no
no see what's up or you can go along the
ridge on the side there [ __ ] you too
playing this like pub G can only get you
so far man I know but it's got me to
28th right now yeah
that's not bad we're in the circle we
can take our time 28 left oh man what if
you don't jinx right right right trying
to figure out where okay we owe your
saying you're busy good spot yeah we
don't have very much anything though
problem I think I got what a place seven
or eight seven or eight my little best
match but uh who knows maybe we'll get
top five top three top one that's asking
for a lot it would be like a lot of
people kind of killing each other off I
mean that's that's just as a legitimate
way to win
you play to win the game all right
there's uh there's there's a town yeah
over there south-southeast snow south of
us now to your West
but yeah we'll go there I'm trying to go
around skrt skrt skrt skrt guys start
building man I didn't see you building
too much
I really wasn't building all that much
I'm not that high level of player yeah
and if you're not a high level player
how can how can I possibly be the one to
be the oh [ __ ] yes someone may have been
here oh yeah there was a chest there as
well so it's right Louie did huh maybe
yeah I don't necessarily loot everything
[Music]
yeah but the shields excited yeah this
the shields will definitely tacos I
don't think you'll have any luck finding
a shield over here man do you oh you
have been oh no bandages can only get
you up to five that's all right oh sorry
oh good 22 in the top 20 mmm that Pope
gee life just just camp it out I guess
yeah that's it's fine I'm not gonna
judge the green AR one shot one
Widowmaker
that's good Oh maybe we can get to that
that's the winning bullet right there
this is probably dangerous move right
here you bi it alright maybe I can get
like so like Nick always complained to
me about how lucky I got with circles so
my hope is that you got like you got
this spot yeah get some ammo it's cool
this place looks like it's been looted
and zooted yeah nothing up there whoo
well circle is closing again yeah
we're an awareness safe zone alright
twenty left's tase in the top twenty in
like his fourth fifth match no like ten
now we died so much in the beginning
it's got to be like 10 yeah I'm sorry
thank you for being so kind as to this
is like you what your first hour
actually playing this to him so you know
we're doing alright I think if you all
think otherwise let us know but don't
hate what do you think they're all a
greasy grow we're gonna have a move
though I forgot what the flight path was
for the bus so I feel like we're gonna
have to go that way you think I feel I
always like I feel like the circle is
gonna get smaller that way and not this
way right no you never know man these
circles are random as hell like I
usually just don't don't move until you
know where you need to go that it create
oh up there yeah on that Ridge maybe
someone's probably staking it out though
I'm always hesitant to get crates in
pubsey an in this game because there's
always eyes on them unless it's already
been looted ooh
16 left is he pursuing you you can shut
from behind you're getting you're
getting your aim sucks getting DP dog
should be building oh why is he building
he shouldn't be building he has nothing
to be afraid of let's go let's go
let's get it three kills man 15 left oh
snap
no time to celebrate field you can do
this you can do this oh dude in booty
13th place that's not second breathe
Sangster
man if you if you picked up bad no
shield I know I should have been doing
this look at this look at this he's
building a dam fort around himself I say
that skill is more important than being
able to build a house man
that was that was good though at least
you at least you know we're ending it on
yeah you're back yeah yeah that's you
it took some time I appreciate the
patience from everyone I didn't have the
best overall loot I don't feel like but
you know you did the best you could we
did what we could with what we were
given
that's what's although I can't see the
circle but yeah I was gonna go north it
was gonna go so I was kind of making the
decision can you pull up the map you
can't I can't hit the decision-making in
terms of like when I ran was probably
bad but the like where I wanted to get
to I think was probably there's no way
in hell I was even gonna try this
tonight no live or die with this AR oh
he missed hmm let's see if our killer
can keep up his momentum
he's got smoking around Oh he hangs on
with a thread we're gonna we're gonna do
uh we can do some casting now we gotta
end this anyways thank you guys so much
for tuning in
we'll be back alive again tomorrow 11:00
a.m. I believe I'm gonna have Joey place
Celeste I might have another one of us
another special guest she's been on a
stream before but I might put her she
might be on another stream so we'll see
tune back in tomorrow 11:00 a.m. and
we'll be back as always next week also
anilinium thank you Michael for
supporting me coaching me but also your
you did a pretty damn good job my
beginning thank you thank you I put up a
show for y'all so I feels good thank you
for having me I really enjoyed this
awesome you see that thing that says
outro yeah the one right click that
you